yeah thanks very much for joining my
talk I'm going to talk about something
light just before lunch so compositional
distributional semantics for modeling
natural language so what it's all about
so if you've ever added to word
embeddings together or you've used word
embeddings as input to a neural network
you've basically applied a composition
functions to distributional word
representations so in this talk I'm
trying to give you some more background
of what's going on in the research area
in that area at the moment and I'll be
focusing on why composition with word
embeddings is actually a really useful
thing and why you should do it
maybe but actually emphasis is my talk
on the current limitations of
compositional approaches because I think
it's probably more important to know
about the shortcomings of a method then
rather than where it excels I'm sorry
it's probably dangerously academic at
times but shouldn't be too bad really
and as I said it's something like just
before lunch so I'll start by just
giving a short intro of what I mean by
compositional distributional semantics
then talk about distributional word
representations and why they're really
really good then go into some of some of
the most common composition functions
that are being used in academia and
probably as well in industry and talk a
bit about their current limitations and
finish with just giving a brief insight
on how compositional methods can be used
baked into a bigger system so what
semantics semantics is the study of the
meaning of words and phrases in some
language and distributional semantics
tries to achieve that by studying the
co-occurrence the districts of different
words in a large corpus of text and then
compositional distributional semantics
tries to build longer units of text out
of elementary distributional
representations subvert representations
are typically based on the
distributional hypothesis going back to
Harrison's first based on the notion of
similar words tend to co-occur in
similar contexts and you probably heard
the famous quote by first saying you
shall know the meaning of a word by the
company it keeps and they also have a
very very long history in NLP research
it didn't just all start recently with
birth defect there was lots of other
stuff going on much earlier going back
probably even to the to the 60s by Karen
sparks Jones and what what we're trying
to achieve is a continuous model of work
meaning but words are represented in a
high dimensional metric space and this
keeps our eyes to a nice a graded notion
of similarity so you can compare like
dog to ket and you'll find they're more
similar than dog and car for example and
more recently we've we've started to
make a distinction between count based
models and predict based ones as an
account based model you explicitly
create a large co-occurrence matrix
keeping track of how often one word Co
occurred with another that's your kind
of traditional PBM I based word
embeddings or also cloth is based on a
explicit called current co-occurrence
matrix and then they apply the matrix
factorization model to it this contrasts
with context based models such as vert
Ravech which never explicitly built this
large co-occurrence matrix but works
implicitly on the kind of concurrent
statistics however all of the models are
usually based on the same underlying
called current statistics in in one way
or another and many of the kind of
performance differences you see across
tasks is often just due to different
kind of hyper parameters and why they
are really cool because they really
capture some very interesting linguistic
regularities and again you've probably
seen this example so you take the vector
King you subtract the vector for men you
add the vector for women and you get
enormously close to the vector for Queen
which is really really cool and you can
measure the semantic similarity between
differ
verts on a continuous scale this is
really is a powerful concept kind of
figuring out that the concept
represented by the vector for dog is
more similar to catch than it is to tank
or car whatever and the algorithm is
unsupervised its
unscalable to very large corpora and
it's also language agnostic so word
Dweck usually doesn't care whether you
feed it English Wikipedia or German
Wikipedia or French Wikipedia will just
happily crunch the data and it's also
they're also kind of plug in place so
you can either download pre-trained word
embeddings the Google News vectors for
example or you just create your own
using chancing or whatever and you add
them to an Opie pipeline and it usually
just works very well and integrates
usually quite seamlessly and
effortlessly and they're also really
flexible so you can use the
off-the-shelf ones and just as a drop-in
you don't really need them to train with
whatever downstream tasks you have but
you actually can if you if you want to
if you need to so bird representations
are really really cool they take all of
the boxes they capture interesting
information they are unsupervised their
language agnostic so it can't get any
better than that really so there's been
lots of effort going into creating
distributional word representations over
of the recent years but at the end of
the day they're only single words and
most of language usually when we study
is usually we are interested in phrases
or sentences or full documents so it
would be nice if there was like the same
off-the-shelf component and creates
meaningful representations out of
individual word vectors the kind of
integrates in a plug-and-play way with
distribution of word representations
offering also the same level of
flexibility kind of you can use them as
ease or you can just fine-tune the
composition function for a given task
and at the moment there's four major
approaches and you've probably used two
of them or at least know about two of
them
so the first one the most simplest one
is just point wise addition and
multiplication of art vectors the second
one is based on the notion of formal
semantics a third one is anchored Peck
trees which is really the most exciting
one of all and there's also just using
them as input into a neural network and
treating a neural network as your
composition function so point wise
addition it's really really simple so
you take your vector for beak you take
your vector for seagull you just add
them together and all to get a phrasal
representation of big seagull one of the
major problems of this approach is that
it's commutative so you went to lots of
lengths into creating those word
representations and then we just add
them together throwing away just lots of
information which is not really
desirable and nonetheless they do
represent annoyingly hard to beat
baseline I've also seen that in my works
just adding vert vert to Veck vectors
together it's just very very difficult
to beat and it's really annoying and
despite the simplicity they capture some
very interesting patterns so if you have
your explicit ppm I pasted Corcoran's
vectors and you multiply them together
then that actually creates a weighted
feature intersection so it only keeps
the features that are common the big and
Siegel in the resulting vector and the
same is true for point wise addition in
neural word embeddings which has been
shown recently and this achieves
something is called contextualization
and which I'll talk about a bit more
later on and also at the end of the day
the problem of commutativity might not
so problematic for one task rather than
another so if you for example two tasks
this text classification then you
probably don't care whether you have
race car car race composed in any way
you want
probably the same anyway but for others
like recognizing textual entailment it's
probably more important to get a kind of
deeper insight into the semantics of a
sentence now the second one is based on
formal semantics which is based on the
notion of function application so an
adjective for example would be acting on
a noun and the linear algebra equivalent
to a function would be a matrix so you
have a matrix for white and the vector
for the noun card you multiply them
together to form the phrase white card
probably be major problem for this
approach is scalability because the
order of the word representation depends
on its category so we have a car which
is a noun which is just a vector so you
could say it's a tensor of all the one
then a matrix an adjective is a matrix
which is a tensor of order 2 and then
are trying to divert such as catch for
examples in seagulls catch fish will be
represented by a third order tensor so
it really gets a bit out of hand here
nonetheless and theoretically sound and
linguistic grounded if you care about
that it's based on Montego Vienna
semantics and it's actually a really
really neat idea but it has some
problems when it comes to putting the
idea in practice one of them being
sentences of different lengths or
different structure often end up with
different dimensionality so we've built
a continuous model sentence meaning then
we have to compare like a third order
tensor with just a vector and it all
falls down a bit and it's definitely
very very difficult to scale beyond just
very short sentences so the next one's
anchored Peck trees that's actually both
were my PhD is based on so if you want
to know anything about them definitely
talk to me later
they're exciting they're brilliant with
them we are living kind of our beloved
vector lens and moving to more
structured grasslands so we represent
words in nodes so the colors denote
different parts of speech so blue node
would be
adjectives green node would be nouns and
the red node would be verbs for example
and the anchor denotes the current view
into the data structure and they
actually like seeing multisets
so it's not just a single word in a node
but there's more than one word so in the
node for white you might find probably
black and green and other colors in
there and the edges are dependent
relations between those words that we
find in the corpus so our major problem
really sparsity because we are counting
co-occurrences but we don't just count
word conquering with the word we also
take the grammatical relation between
those two words into account so the
dimensionality of the space really
really explodes and in some of my
experiments so having a two million
dimensional space is just normal really
and sparsity really is a problem and
instead of just reading in Wikipedia as
it is we first parse Wikipedia and then
feed it through our algorithm as I said
the nodes are represented by ppm I
awaited licks in multi sets and the
edges are represented by dependency
relations and so the two structures if
you look at the the white structure and
the rabid structure they are kind of
different they live in a different space
so in order to be able to compose the
two together we need to do an additional
step which we call offsetting and which
really just takes the representation for
white and kind of projects it into the
noun space and then the two can be
composed together the last and currently
probably most successful and yeah most
popular compositional functions are just
neural networks so you have your kind of
look of layer here with your word
representations then the neural network
actually is your composition function so
this can be your convolutional neural
network or your bi-directional tree
based lsdm with
tension or whatever people are using
these days and at the end you usually
have a downstream objective that you're
going to optimize so one problem for
that is the transferability because the
composition function is kind of tied to
a specific task and plugging the learn
model into another task often fails so
if you train your model on the text
classification task and then we want to
do paraphrasing then the text
classification model probably doesn't
work very well the composition function
is learned as part of an end-to-end
rule from the data and its really really
tailored to the one task you give it and
different tasks often require different
kinds of composition composition
functions so it's not really a general
purpose of plug-and-play because you
really need to retrain it with a given
task from stripe from scratch every time
also there's currently lots of progress
being made for kind of multi task
learning kind of having multiple
objectives all working on the main
adaption kind of adapting one net for
for another to main and despite all of
those tailoring and tweaking and tweaks
of AWS time that you've spent y'all so
much is only really small improvements
over just adding word to vectors
together as I said adding word to
vectors just works really well in this
really annoying somehow that's nice too
so it's not all that bad really
all major approaches that we're
currently using they have some issues
with one form or another and composition
functions
unlike word representations and not yet
such a nice and general-purpose dropping
but they are reasonably practical and
useful I'm sure many of you have used
them but there's there's definitely more
problems
which is how do you measure which one's
the best evaluating composition
functions is quite hard and it's
probably the Achilles heel of current
research is there's no really there's
not really a good way to determine which
composition function is better than
another
and if you've been to mirrors talk on
labeling gold standard data yesterday on
map this talk on evaluating topic models
you probably do know that evaluation is
really important for compositional
models is either based on a phrase
similarity task or some sentence
similarity task in comparison to human
judgment and similarity for humans is
already quite difficult on just the word
level and the task doesn't get any
easier with more words second way our
models are evaluated is just on some
downstream tasks but there's just too
many factors that can influence
performance so it's not really a clear
picture of the composition function
itself and it is definitely difficult to
design a good task because we need to
figure out what we actually try to
measure is it the generality of a
composition function across many
downstream tasks and without any
retraining of a model or is it a
specific one so the continuous model of
work building on the sentence level is
probably very close to paraphrasing or
is it more interesting for in 10 line
kind of what inferences can you draw
from a sentence representation or is it
actually really task specific so we
might figure out that just training a
neural network on one downstream task is
good enough and we can't do any better
otherwise but there's actually a few
more issues so taking a bit of a global
more global point of view even if
everything will be working perfectly and
there's a question what does a sentence
actually mean so if you imagine your
vertical current space you can pin down
some nouns over here and some adjectives
over there and that that makes sense but
how does this work for sentences where
should they be and the longer a sentence
becomes the more difficult it becomes to
determine what the sentence actually
means so I've kind of copied out the
random sentence from from a Wikipedia
article and it's about some battle
probably not very significant in the
1,700 somewhere in Britain
and you can ask a lot of questions about
that one sentence so who fought who when
was the battle where was the battle who
won the battle and it's very difficult
so the question is should the sentence
like this really be encoded in a single
vector are 300 dimensions of work to
Vega whatever really enough to kind of
encode all of the gory details of that
sentence one answer to that is by
Professor Remo me he said you can't
really crime the whole mini add meaning
of a whole flippin sentence into a
single flip in vector and the problem is
also not just philosophical it's also
very practical because if you use an
intersective compositional function in
your explicit ppm I Corcoran space you
might just run out of features at some
point and end up with an empty vector
which is pretty meaningless on the other
hand if you kind of add those vectors
all together you're accumulating too
much information and that one vector is
now kind of similar to pretty much
everything because he then coded too
much information
okay so I've talked a lot about kind of
wide composition is flawed it actually
is good for something as well so it
leverages existing resources effectively
so word representations are really great
they encode a lot of meaningful
information in a very limited amount of
dimensions in space and composition also
achieves kind of contextualization so if
you usually in any kind of text you have
some issues with polysemy like the word
tank can mean a river bank or a
financial institution and if you only
have a single vector representing things
then you actually create a weighted sum
of the different usages so if you see
the financial institutions and more
often the kind of vector is more pushed
towards that way as opposed to the river
bank meaning and if you compose that
composition has a sense discriminating
effect so you kind of recover some of
the sense specific information and with
some context polysemy might actually not
be such
huge problem at all and this even works
for simple composition functions as
we've shown in a paper earlier this year
so if you just take virtu Veck
and you add river and bank and you
inspect the nearest neighbors you kind
of get into a Riverside neighborhood
if you compose Bank in the count just by
point wise addition again you kind of
get into a financial institution
neighborhood so this is really nice
because you don't have to kind of create
st. specific embeddings you can just
create one like the pervert and then use
composition kind of leverage that and
it's already been used successfully in
many different systems ranging from
parsing machine translation sentiment
analysis and so on but it's not yet a
plug-and-play in general purpose and for
the remainder I'll pre flee talk about
to kind of use cases of how composition
can be used as part of a larger system
one of them is going to be aspect based
sentiment analysis and the other one
being question answering
so in aspect based sentiment analysis
you're not just interested in the
overall sentiment of a review but in
some very specific aspects so for a
camera you're probably interested in in
the lens or the battery or the weight
and if you just care about the full
sentiment review then some kind of bag
of words plus tf-idf and an SVM at the
end it's going to be good enough and
it's definitely going to be hard to beat
but if you care about a knowledge on the
sentence level for specific aspects you
need a more fine-grained understanding
of what is going on and can give you a
more detailed insight of what makes a
reviewer three or four out of five
instead of a five out of five and that's
quite an interesting problem because if
you have a review that that's four out
of five stars that's yeah that's
positive the product is being liked but
there was something that was kind of
wrong with it and you can use
composition the kind of figure out what
was wrong and kind of illustrated
these guys are goona an adult and they
create a compositional representation of
each sentence in in a review and this
gives them like a continuous
representation and continuous scale of
similarity between different parts of a
sentence and what they do is they create
multiple representations per sentence so
if you have a sentence like I like the
lens but the battery was crap they'll
kind of extract lens with its
surrounding context like light lens and
same with battery battery crap and then
they'll just composed two together to
kind of get a notion of what is being
said about batteries and lenses and this
is so composition is quite a good way to
identify common issues that are being
talked about in many reviews and it's a
bit of a longer shot it can provide an
insight of what individuals look for in
a review so if I travel a lot and I say
well the camera was nice but it was much
too heavy then this can give you insight
that I really care about the weight of
the products I buy so somebody please
recommend me light stuff for
question-answering and it's another way
how you can use composition with
distributional semantic vectors so
traditionally it's been set up as a kind
of information retrieval problem where
the goal is to retrieve the most
relevant answers to given questions if
you have an answer candidates then the
most relevant is usually the right
answer and it's a good way to exploit
distributional representations of
answers and questions and composition
can really leverage their commonalities
and figure out what kind of semantic
content they share and again composition
here achieves the context realization of
content words and acts as a mechanism to
integrate all of the knowledge from this
individual words into a longer phrase so
if you have an example question like
what was the name of the fascist
dictator of Italy during the Second
World War it leaves quite polysemous
here so you can mean the geographical
say
veturi like I'm going to Italy this
summer or the political science of Italy
kind of Italy urging the European Union
for help in the refugee crisis or the
kind of sport sense of Italy kind of
Italy being defeated by Austria in the
World Cup by laughing that will happen
so and you have three answer candidates
and by composing Italy with fascistic
data in world war two you kind of get
into a neighborhood that kind of
historical political and you would
assume that a vector representation of
the named entity Benito Mussolini will
create enough overlap at least in
comparison to the other answer candidate
to kind of get you the right answer to
the composed question yeah and obviously
this composition is not just restricted
to single named entity type questions
and answers but can also be applied to
more complex answers and already almost
at lunch so distributional word
representations are really great and
composition is a good way to effectively
leverage these existing resources
composing work gravity it does work but
it has its limitations and different
composition functions which I've
presented has different shortcomings so
on the one hand you have like the
unsupervised and very general methods
just like adding and on the other hand
you have supervised in very specific
composition functions like a neural
network and a very important issue is
how to evaluate them which one is really
the best and it's a very hot topic
probably as we speak there are multiple
papers posted on archive that are
talking about composition in one way or
another and it's lots of progress being
made pretty much on a weekly basis
almost and yeah that's it so thank you
[Applause]
thanks for the talk and you mentioned
the one slide that people are starting
to take pee train models and gear them
towards a specific task and between
google word Tyvek i wondered if you
could mention maybe how people are doing
that generally you mean like the
multitask learning or automated app to
the general method of adaption like the
single or multi task I've seen it done
in speech recognition for example where
they can take a pre trained speech
recognition model and then somehow put
like a last layer which is really good
at medical terms you know that work is
there as that's yeah that's that's
usually how it's being transferred so
usually you take some of the hidden
layers and plug it into a different task
and then you just usually just fine-tune
the task so these guys move at all have
shown this works really really well if
you have kind of semantically related
tasks so if you kind of have a
classification task and maybe a
sentiment analysis task and you use you
learn hidden layers for sentiment
analysis it works really well and you
only have to a bit of retuning but if
you use like the transfer from text
classification to paraphrasing or
parsing or whatever then it fails
because the two tasks are not too much
related to each other thank you
interesting talk Thanks it's just what
curiosity I was wondering if you ever
work with a simple model which you still
some the word embeddings but you have an
order on on which you do the sums and
the order is based on the Aurora click
on the syntax impact our sinks so and
what if you play with it and what were
the results because I have a feeling
that just these simple things might work
there would you still just add them
together
oh yeah but for instance you take the
order you take like towards our
connectedness in that person so you send
those to then those two are connected
with another one and then you sum the
result of that one with with the other
one just following the structure of the
simpad syntax tree but not even if you
sum them they would come in a weighted
sum or to mean just you cannot be I and
also using the weighted area English as
a shot so could be see yeah that's
that's similar for project immediately
recursive networks that use to kind of
create the composition all the way up to
a sentence from individual words yeah
but I meant in distance you don't need
to use the the network at the end but
just summing them based on the on the on
whether they are connected or not
through the resistor that step that's
definitely a good way that's probably a
good intermediate between like plain
adding and a full neural network yeah
and it's not not to over engineer to
complicate much and probably already
have some get better results
yeah thank you
maybe I just missed it but we're in
these pictures
our topic models or latent semantic
technologies I'm kind of wondering
whether I mean there is an edit value'
from your point of view to represent
words as higher dimensional concept
whatever that means
so latent semantic analysis I think you
usually also add them together so they
book kind of play in the Edit of space
topic modeling is a bit like in-between
there because you have like the those
probabilities over topics and the
adherence to two different documents so
yeah they are out of those four that I
represented
hi maybe a stupid question but I was
wondering with the with composed
semantics is there an idea of whether
you need more dimensions than for the
word embeddings like in word embeddings
I guess the sweet spot has been found to
be about 300 dimensions so especially
with the more advanced composition
method you presented is there an idea
what sort of a sweet spot is there what
you end up with an odor so at least I
haven't found one yet I think in machine
translation people have kind of settled
on a thousand dimension as a bit of a
sweet spot so because there needs to be
just more room for information to be
encoded but generally you know we
haven't found like a really good number
that works well like the 304 virtual
presentations
so that's less of a question and more of
a follow-up from the previous one
there's been a lot of work most notably
from say Marco Barone's group where they
don't really have a fixed dimensionality
for every word but rather they they have
like a vector for nouns and then verbs
would be two-dimensional as matrices and
the intuition being that if you want to
do compositions in is matrix
multiplication then you want the you
want to verb to be a more complex thing
because it needs to take argument so the
matrix multiplication is effectively a
function that takes two nouns and same
goes for adjectives so the way to add
more dimensions is not by just having a
single vector that's longer but by going
into a matrix or a 3d tensor yeah I
you mean like the formal semantics based
approach to the composition yeah yeah so
my question then that follows me that is
how do you how do you see all that can a
very theoretical work coming in from
physics and like Bob Cox work how do you
see that fitting with the neural network
trend um well those people like Baroni
and and popcopy' and stuff they've
already moved on to neural networks now
more or less completely so I still think
like representing Verte adjectives as
matrices and kind of work system so it's
a neat idea to kind of integrate
semantic composition on a month ago vien
kind of point of view into
distributional semantics but it doesn't
scale very well because the kind of
matrices you need to learn get out of
hand and you need to learn different
matrices depending on whether a noun is
in an object position or in a in a
subject position what was a question
with regards to how it relates to neural
networks or do you see the - I think
compatible would you reckon there is a
way to put those two together somehow
and say maybe use a neural net to learn
the tensors for a more Montagu Levin
that's amount that could work yeah I
mean the other matrices they used
trained based owns the gas
gradient descent and kind of usual
optimization techniques that using
neural nets anyway so probably yes so
maybe neural nets can help create better
adjective matrix for example there are
other questions I have one in your
overview you gave four approaches one is
missing namely the one that was proposed
by Coakley and Thomas nickel off I mean
honest dr. Beck it's almost not like a
word so it's called paragraph factors
turtle acha acha doc dr. Zack did you do
it on purpose because a bit yes all
right
it didn't it didn't so well fit into the
clean story because I'm not an expert on
on paragraph factor so I can't comment
too much on it but it's it's kind of it
plays in the neural networks field
because they learn like a paragraph
vector with the paragraph ID so
optimizing some of downstream function
so it's kind of in in the neural network
field I would argue okay if there are no
other questions then let's thank the
speaker again
you